对于SP06
Core Data Service HDBDD
在HANA SP05中，我们引入了通过仓库创建大多数数据库对象的概念
大多数情况下是通过创建一个hdbtable的文件
当这个文件被激活的时候会在指定的数据目录中生成一个表
这样做是为了分离和抽象出创建或更改表结构的SQL
开发人员要做的就是维护这个设计时的表现结构(hdbtable文件)
当文件被激活的时候必要的SQL会被自动创建
当然，HANA也是完全具有执行SQL语句能力的数据库
然而，这样创建仓库对象的做法有额外的能力
它使我们很容易地传输数据库对象而不能重新在目标系统上执行
创建或者更改数据库的SQL语句，仅仅通过传输设计时的表结构
当在目标系统上激活时，必要的SQL语句会生成并被执行
HANA也允许我们在SQL语法上增加可能的东西，例如
多语言，数据表列说明等
SAP最终是把HANA做为一个完整的数据字典
不仅有能力定义表对象
还能定于对象之间的关系
甚至继续抽象出简单的基于SQL的查询语言
允许我们访问对象之间的定义关系
现在首先介绍一下SP06中CDS(Core Data Service)
和新开发工件HDBDD
DD是指数据字典(Data Dictionary)
CDS包含三个主要部分
一个是数据定义语言，非常类似于今天说的hdbtable，hdbstructure等
但是CDS是一个单一的语言和开发对象
能使你在SP06中创建表和数据结构
而且扩展了使用同一种CDS语法定义数据库视图和其他对象的能力
事实上，以后所有的HANA对象设计都要使用CDS语法
CDS也是一种查询语言
故我们可以用CDS来定义对象之间的关联关系
说到查询语言，CDS也仅是结构查询语言(SQL)的扩展
所以我们可以访问这些关系之间的关系，如SaleOrder.Item
在运行时就知道他们之间是一对多的关系，一个SalesOrder有多个Item
复杂内连接在幕后自动生成以简化查询语言`
这样做是为了简化开发人员所写的代码和重用已定义的关系
最后CDS也是一种表达式语言
CDS可以允许我们定义更加复杂的行为和表达式
SP06暂时只支持数据定义语言，还不具备定义对象关联关系能力
不过在不久的将来就会被实现加入
过渡期间使用hdbtable，hdbstructure和新的hdbdd
hdbtable和hdbstructure是完全支持的
我现在给你展示一下新的CDS编辑器长啥样
和作为开发者，定义表，结构以及重用表时的体验
回到SAP HANA Studio中上次视频中用新向导创建的工程中
创建的xsjsaccess和xsjs文件
我们已经创建了一个SP6Demo Schema
我们可以看到现在其中还没有创建任何表，结构和内容
我们创建一个小且简单，存储用户详细信息的User表，如id
在后面的演示中你可以看到这个User表在SP06中新功能
现在让我们开始在data文件夹中，用向导创建一个DDL Souce File
向导创建了一个文件名是User.hdbdd并打开了CDS编辑器
你应该知道在SP06中CDS编辑器只是一个文本编辑器
并且SP06是具有智能语法高亮
在SP07中，我们打算加入图形模式来定于表和结构
你还可以在图形模式和编辑模式中来回切换
可以看到文件的命名空间是包层级结构
命名空间不需要改动，在CDS中有一个context
context的概念就是我们要生成对象名字的一部分
比如我可以有一个context是SalesOrder包括header和item实体
那么生成的目录就是SalesOrder.Header和SalesOrder.Item
我只想创建一个简单的User表，也许后面我还想创建一个Address表，等等
我现在写一些特别的注释
将会把这个对象创建到sp6demo中
现在让我创建一些可以重用的类型
SString短字符，长度为40
这就是可重用字典的价值所在
简单类型，复杂类型可用在不同的实体中重用
这里我只想演示简单的例子，再创建一个长度为255长字符类型LString
重用类型已经创建好了，现在来创建一个列存储的数据表
数据表在CDS中也是一个实体
现在创建PERS_ID为表的主键，类型是长度为10的字符串
就像你看到到，我不能在Entity里面创建重用类型
在创建first_name, last_name两列类型为SString, email列类型为LString
保存并激活hdbdd文件
激活成功后，回到SP6Demo目录中
表sp6.data::User.Detail生成了，包名就是命名空间
::是命名空间分隔符，User.Datail是表名
现在看一下表的定义，看到每一行都正确的生成了
并且重用类型被扩展为列声明试的类型
现在让我给你展示一个更加复杂的例子
这我以在SP05中介绍的EPM模型为例子
如果你以前看过，以前有很多hdbdd文件来定义不同的表
但是现在只有一个文件，这样的好处是一个hdbdd文件包含多个表的定义
而我们所需要的对象都在一个文件中（更好的重用）
它的context是EPM，包含了一些简单和复杂的重用类型
比如开始和结束时间很多地方要用到，这里只需定义一个类型ValidityT
在表的内部可以直接重用这个复杂类型ValidityT
另外context也可以被嵌套使用
这个例子EPM context就内嵌了MasterData context
因此Addresses表就会创建为EPM.MasterData.Addresses的表
你可以看到类型的重用是如此的简单，因为可以直接使用ValidityT作为列类型。
因为Addresses重用了ValidityT,所以现在Addresses中就有开始和结束时间两列
类型也有作用域范围，有些类型全局的是属于EMP context的一部分
另外一些类型属于内部类型，比如nameT是属于MasterData context
这里在MasterData中定义了Address, Business Partner, Employee等表结构
这里也定于了Sales, Contact，Purchase的header和item实体。
我想你已经大致了解了。
激活这个hdbdd文件，回到SP6Demo数据库目录中
首先看下Procedures,可以看到可重用的表类型
回到上面，可以看到比如ValidityT，HistoryT被定义为可重用的表类型
打开它们的定义，可以在下拉框里看出是声明的表类型
这些表类型也可以被用在SQL存储过程中
用来定义存储过程，不仅可以在存储过程中声明表类型
在EPM中可以声明一个Procedure Context，声明所有的输入输出参数
这样就可以在一处声明重用的表类型在分享重用，而就不用在每个存储过程中重复声明
当你看生成的表时，你会发现它们都遵守命名规则并组织良好
遵循规则为   命名空间::Context.表名称
表在相同的context下被组织在一起，如Purchase, Sale，Util等
看MasterData下的Addresses表定义，每一行都是在hdbdd中定义的
Addresses还重用了ValidityT类型
故在表中看到有Validity.startDate和Validity.EndDate
在定义时，只需定义一个类型为ValidityT的列Validity
如果新增加一个新的字段，所有使用ValidityT的表都会拥有
重用最后会实现字段在属性（类型，注释等）在不同表之间的一致性。